almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it okay I want
to get ahead of what is going to be a
barrage of absolute BS garbage math this
is what I'm calling a garbage math you
were going to be hit left and right by
garbage math over the next few months
and the goal of the garbage math will be
for you to think that Donald Trump
deserves to be re-elected and we've
already been starting to see some of
what I'm calling garbage math with
coronavirus for a while so for example
when trumpets talk about the total
number of tests that have been done in
the United States that's garbage math it
doesn't tell us very much tests per day
are what matter tests per capita or what
matter we're four months into this thing
right the cumulative number of tests
that have been done tell us very very
little
another example over the last couple of
months we've seen such economic
destruction that it now opens the door
to wild meaningless claims about growth
rates in certain industries which are
already being touted as huge victories
now I want to give you a really specific
example there's been this headline
floating around air travel surges air
travel and bookings surged a hundred and
twenty percent in New York Times
actually wrote about this when this
started being touted so understand when
coronavirus hit air travel dropped by
one estimate ninety six percent
so when you say air travel surges a
hundred and twenty percent it has surged
a hundred and twenty percent are roughly
doubled from almost zero okay so
imagining that air travel is going well
completely ignores just basic math let's
look at some numbers if you start with
what would be one hundred percent right
like full air travel and you then
experience a 96 percent decrease to air
travel you end up
with four percent of the air travel you
started with you start with something
you take away 96 percent you're left
with four percent if you then increase
air travel by a hundred and twenty
percent air travel is still down 91
percent from where it was this is just a
common function of how percentages and
growth rates work if you lose 50 percent
of something you need to gain 100
percent to get back to where you were if
I have $100 in stock and that stock
loses 50% of its value my hundred
dollars is now worth $50 to get back to
$100
I need that 50 bucks to increase 100
percent and this is the crux of a ton of
the disinformation propaganda propaganda
garbage math that you are going to be
hit with over the next few months as the
recovery hopefully starts to happen
depending on how deadly coronavirus
remains and how bad wave 2 is you are
going to see a lot of this stuff I'll
give you some other examples jobs have
so imploded that they will start using
job growth numbers that will be
meaningless because of the base numbers
that are being used understand that we
lost more than 20% of our workforce so
far we might recover 5% of the current
workforce and they will say hey we're
already a quarter of the way back that's
not how growth rates work if you lose
20% of the workforce and then you gain
back 5% of that reduced number you're
only gaining 19% of what you lost not
twenty five so understand how these
growth rates work the one that will
really be weaponized is probably going
to be GDP we in all likelihood are going
to see historic GDP lost numbers for the
second quarter in the United States
we're not going to get those numbers
until sometime in August most likely so
normally the numbers would be for
example like OGD P and Q two went up
point five percent usually you annualize
that so 0.5 percent over four
would be like on track for 2% GDP growth
for the year okay the decline in the
second quarter is going to be massive it
could be ten percent could be twelve
percent could be 25 percent imagine it's
15 percent if you annualize that 15
percent one-quarter loss it would be
like 60 percent for the year it's not
going to really tell us much because in
all likelihood in the third quarter if
things go as are sort of expected we're
going to start to see a recovery and
remember that recovery in GDP would only
be a fraction of what was lost in the
second quarter the headlines and Trump
and others are going to say for example
imagine that we lose 15 percent in q2
and gain 5 percent in q3 relative to
those previous numbers the trumpet will
say oh my god
five percent in a quarter we're on track
for 20 percent GDP growth if you
annualize it even China doesn't grow 20
percent in a year and of course that
would be wrong because we will have just
suffered one of the if not the greatest
GDP loss in America in American history
and there would be no reason to
annualize third quarter GDP growth if we
have it given that it is a year with
massive ups and downs so the the concern
I have is that the timing of that could
be very very pernicious we are likely to
learn the q3 GDP numbers at the end of
October that is days before the
presidential election and it is going to
present the perfect opportunity for
Donald Trump to do what will essentially
be like 96 hours of propaganda confusing
people about q3 GDP numbers to justify
his reelection and it may work I'm
trying to stay ahead of it I don't want
you to fall for the garbage math and the
reason why it's important to understand
is that this is one would there's a
couple different things first of all you
don't want to get tricked by bad math we
all want to have basic math and
statistics understanding but number two
policymaker
are going to be using bad data to
justify the policies that they would be
advocating for anyway and pretending
like it's where the facts are taking us
when the reality is they'd be advocating
for the same policies no matter what and
they'd be advocating for the re-election
of Donald Trump no matter what they will
claim victory they will claim mission
accomplished
understand growth rates understand
percentages don't fall for the garbage
math make sure you're following me on
Twitter let me know what other fuzzy
math you were seeing for lack of a
better term and remember that you can
get the daily David Pakman show audio
podcast for free on iTunes stitcher
google play podcasts all of your
favorite podcasting platforms sign up
free and get the daily podcast